there's so much blockage of the sun
these days it feels like and like
finally people are looking up and being
like oh why does this guy look like a
grid and you know it is completely
confirmed through news and the
government that they do spray chemicals
in the air and that Chemtrails are a
real thing obviously the last few years
have been nuts and there's been so many
things to put us into a fierce State and
put us keep us indoors avoiding the
light actually my friend just sent me a
Instagram video that showed someone
walking on the streets and somewhere in
LA and there's an advertisement for a
building to live in that's a that's an
underground building like oh yeah I saw
that yeah I mean like to you don't need
to go outside again and I just feel like
they are trying to now depress us and
drive us crazy without by blocking
sunlight and and sure enough it usually
seems like whenever those Chemtrails are
up there the next day is cloudy
absolutely
research tell us yeah and I mean I've
been talking about this for 15 years you
know I've to the point where it's like
it was it was falling on deaf ears for
so long and the whole thing where no
those are contrails when contrails lost
maximum seven seconds in the atmosphere
and you can actually see that you know
they turn on and turn off and turn on
and turn off which ends that debate
right there this has been going on since
the 40s you know it's been you know
weather modification
um you know weaponizing weather and
really understanding that this is this
is a serious problem which is basically
evolved into this concept where we're
not observing the Earth because that's
really how they're rolling it out is
that they're blocking UVA and UVB rays
because of global warming that's the
whole story now and that's the
geoengineering story is that what an
awesome way of keeping the core of the
earth cool and keeping the surface of
the Earth cool by spraying metallic
atmospheric particulates strontium
barium aluminum into the into the into
the Sky cover and have it reflect the
sun back out into space that's the story
it's such an Abomination it's so gnarly
this is an existential threat in my
opinion
um this is something that you just you
can't walk away from because this stuff
is making its way everywhere it's
getting it's microns size so it's
getting into people's lungs it's getting
into the soil and like you said father
son I mean that is that's our core
energy source of every biochemical in
nature and in our body and endogenous
and it's it's part of the production of
the life cycle that's we're dealing with
some strange stuff and the whole thing
did you see my post yesterday I was
talking about you know this we we need
the life force of the Sun but we also
have to understand the Sun so it's not
like you can't just be someone who wears
sunblock for 20 years and then take a
trip to Costa Rica and think that you
can just go stand in front of the Sun
for 12 hours right it there's a common
sense approach and this whole beauty
industry about the sunlight is you know
damaging you and dangerous to you again
Common Sense approach sunlight gives you
life sunlight activates 3000 genes
associated with longevity that we know
of wow it's it's you know it's the Core
Essence of our circadian rhythm so
without sunlight On The Rise if you're
not getting it into your eyes and
getting it onto your body your body's
immune system is not turning on your
clock isn't turning on I can go on and
on melatonin is produced from sunlight
and melatonin we know is not just the
sleep you know hormone it's actually one
of the strongest antioxidants in our
system even more than glutathione why
when the Sun goes down does it serve
does it have a wiser melatonin search
right because it's when the Sun goes
down that the surge of melatonin comes
that's correct yeah so it's building
that reservoir on the rise so the the
Rising Sun builds the reservoir of
melatonin and then and then the body
responds by releasing that melatonin
throughout the brain and body and
intracellularly as the sun makes its
declination to the Easter to the east so
as the sun moves away from us and as
long as we're not you know shrouded in
you know I would say pollutionary light
blue light spectrums like that melatonin
expands and releases throughout the body
and serves as a major antioxidant and
it's it's actually creating redox in the
body where it's lending electrons to
free radicals throughout the body from
brain to toe very interesting and that's
why you know I'm sure you've been in a
campfire or you know fires everything
right so fire is very similar with the
sun's Rays to a certain extent it's
offering certain nanometers of light
waves and infrared
which is leading to the system and it's
actually releasing stress and cortisol
throughout the body that's why you sit
in front of a fire for an hour in a camp
you're ready to go to sleep usually you
have the best sleep ever yeah or if you
have the ability to get a red light they
recommend doing red light sunrise sunset
to mimic because really red light is
just pulling a certain a little narrow
spectrum of what the sun offers
um right to help with the Circadian
rhythm and help with sort of waking up
and going to sleep and keeping because
it's about the Rhythm right that's right
yep and I do red light every other day
on the rise and almost every evening
um you know around 7 30 8 o'clock yeah
and uh it's part of the ritual and it's
so many benefits on just everything I
mean it's all common sense with your
health you know it's not like we can
isolate or looking at it allopathically
you know it's like red light raises ATP
or red light lowers cytochrome b or
whatever it is we get sometimes so
allopathic that we don't realize that by
it doing one thing means it's doing so
many other things and it's got an
evolutionary aspect to it that's part of
our entire Doctrine and our physiology
of being humans and that's where the
spirit comes into play so we get out of
the left brain analytical biohacking
energy and we start looking at these
things as evolutionary and understanding
that the human body was designed with a
set of instructions you know we're Earth
made you know you and you and I are
filled with minerals of the earth like
how trippy is that body is actually made
of what we walk on right and we don't
even know we don't even know what's
under us
such a trip that's why we have to ground
to the Earth that's why we drink spring
water that's why we mineralize our body
oh I think I saw you say something
something about being careful how much
of that you put in your water for
hydration is that true how much of what
is specifically minerals and salt or you
know sodium potassium chlorine all the
different minerals and whatnot is that
dangerous or is it good to put it in
your water all the time I think it
depends like you know some person's
medicines another person's poison we
have to really approach things
practically with who we are where we are
why we are how we live our lives things
of that nature you know and so
mineralization is foundation to health
getting electrolytes getting sea salt in
your body especially on the rise
especially around your vigorous workouts
it's critical but you can overdo it of
course and then there's wrong form
minerals things that are made you know
industrial you know byproduct products
that have no no basis of being in our
body and actually create damage and
hardening of the body that's when you
get fibrotic tissue and over
calcification of the body and things of
that nature and so our body again I came
with a set of instruction we have we
have Cycles in our life you know my
body's different than when I was 14
right and so it's it requires different
things at different stages there's a
24-hour cycle there's a seven day cycle
and there's a 28-day cycle and a seven
year cycle in the way that we need to
approach our health and this is
additional Chinese herbal medicine this
is an ayurvedic approach but they all
correlate with new formed understanding
of how our immune system works how stem
cells work in the body all these
different things
um all kind of you know meet together at
some at some Summit it's a lot of cool
stuff here this is this is what I love
to this is what I love to do you know
I'm glad you mentioned stem cells that I
was curious I wasn't sure we get to it
or not but um so you're talking about
these Cycles is there something
appropriate for each cycle like the one
day the one week the 28 days and the
seven years is their use in those Cycles
is it like hey every day you should be
doing this and every week you should
make sure you include this or is it more
of a Cascade that when you do each day
right it leads into the next seven years
you'll be a different body because every
seven years we have a whole new body is
that correct that's right and we go
through it we go through a shift every
seven years in the in the multiple
complex systems in the body whether it's
our you know you know our Nero system
our cardio system our digestive system
all of those things they shift a little
bit things change hormones change
thyroid changes
um the way that we receive information
changes our oral health changes all
those things start to make a different
shift and so you're right how you do
anything is how you do everything so
every day you know you're creating an
opportunity to not only you know get
feel healthy but to thrive and to get
better and better I do think that there
are systems
um depending on people's Constitution
um that would you know lead us into
stronger health and lead us into more of
a resilient Health uh you hear a lot of
the geneticists today talking about how
we have a health span and we have a
disease span and once you leave the
health span you enter the disease span
and getting back to the health span once
you're in the disease state is a lot
more difficult than keeping a life
filled in that state and we're in
interesting times you know it is what
what's happened over the last hundred
years to our atmosphere like we just
talked about to our water to our soil to
our food to our education to the fear to
the scarcity all of these things are
destructionary forces that are the
opposite of centropy which is a place of
symbiotic Evolution where everything is
coming together to create a utopic
paradise and we're in such fight flight
rage High to energy with scarcity then
you have all the physiological aspects
that are falling apart we're not getting
sunlight we're living in in industrial
warehouses you know we're living in
artificial boxes we're controlling the
temperature and the lighting not pulled
away from nature that right there in
itself doesn't allow us to pull on to to
our hormetic codes and what do I mean by
that hormesis that which does not kill
you makes you stronger and so we're no
longer hunting for our spring water and
you know growing our own food and
putting in all this effort for the
sustainable things that we need to
survive and so that's not activating
well they call it now sirtuin Pathways
longevity Pathways so we're just you
know we're sedentary more than ever you
know we're we're sitting on the couch
we're laying in our bed we're sitting in
a car we're doing all these things these
things are keeping us from pulling on
the strings of being active and pulling
on the strings of surviving if you like
this clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen